foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censor tonight the
deadly Race Against Time a massive
Rescue Mission underway of the North
Atlantic after a sun went missing on his
voyage to the Titanic I talked to a
friend of the missing British
billionaire on board and get the very
latest from a panel of experts also
tonight British school children
identifying as cats horses and dinosaurs
and in some cases demanding to
communicate in animal noises is this the
logical conclusion of Limitless
self-identity and if it is can I be a
cat or debate versus England lose a
thrilling first test match for Australia
and the ashes will debate whether
Cricket is as I believe the greatest
sport in the world with qriket Legend
David Lloyd and a U.S Sports commentator
who thinks we're all completely bonkers
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening Fernando welcome to
Facebook and uncensored it wasn't so
long ago that when teachers asked
children what they want to be they meant
what profession now they're asking them
which animal object or beast they may
identify as and tethering their lessons
accordingly it's just satire it's a
genuine story it's true it's going on in
schools up and down the country and for
those of us who have warned for years
about the inevitable consequence of
Limitless self-identity it sadly won't
come as a surprise but it is shocking
this Story begins with a video that
circulated yesterday of a teacher in
England scolding two pupils for refusing
to accept that one of their classmates
identified as a cat
crazy
the question I was just saying about the
gender I haven't said anything about
them but once you get this idea from
there's only two genders gender is not
linked to do with them
gender is about how you identify
there is actually quite large you
shouldn't be born into steps you can be
born with male and female body parts in
terms of gender there are lots of
candidates it's another time
but you identify with the gender that of
the sexual organ that you're born with
that's basically what you're saying yeah
which is really despicable
despicable so the age of 13 those
students who were wise enough to express
an honestly held opinion which is one
most people in the world would share or
for that their own teacher says they're
despicable and if they hold that view
they should go to a different school
that view being that girls have vaginas
and boys have penises that's so
despicable they would have to leave the
school
I think what's despicable in that
exchange is what that teacher said the
daily telegrapher they followed up were
interviewing pupils of schools across
the United Kingdom for a major
investigation it read like a fast like
they made it up but it was actually true
they came up with all sorts of examples
from all over the country that looked
like we were living on frankly a
different planet to the one that most of
us think we're living on
which makes sense because some of the
kids they write about are identifying as
alien life forms literally on a
different planet
they said the children in high schools
have been allowed to self-identity as
cats horses dinosaurs even a moon not
the Moon
a moon and they're deadly serious about
this
Optimus causes disruption in lessons a
telegraph reported because in some cases
they'll only communicate in animal
noises
pupils at schools where children
identify as cats complain to the
newspaper that classes are dominated by
the children because they insist on
meowing
this is not a joke this is serious
one people at a state Secondary School
in Wales so the fellow people feels very
discriminative against if you do not
refer to them as cat self
Telegraph discovered that the people at
one high school is insisting on being
addressed as a dinosaur another as a
horse one wears a cable wants to be
acknowledged like I said as a moon
the children are allowed to wear items
like cats ears while other human
identifying children are rebuked for
untucked shirts well enough is enough
put it this way what would you feel if I
said I'm a cat
seriously I do actually feel quite
feline I took in two kittens in January
my first pets I've had since I was a
teenager uh two little Burmese kittens
called Dennis and Bobby for Arsenal fans
named after berkamp and Pires and I
frankly now feel like one of them
they're like identify as a cat I snack a
lot I enjoy regular naps I have higher
than average intelligence I'm curious
and inquisitive I have a natural born
predatory instinct when it comes to
attacking Rivals to attack me and
everywhere I go people want to stroke my
chin and call me cute so so yes I'm a
cat
but there's one problem
I'm a human really I'm not actually a
cat
scientifically and biologically I'm a
human being
incontrovertibly it's a fact
much as I'd like to enjoy the benefits
of being a cat 20 hours naps no taxes
Meals On Demand when I cry I can't
because I'm not a cat
now if all of this is shocking to you
it's probably because you haven't been
paying attention most of these teachers
are probably trying to do the right
thing terrified of being reported for
bigotry for failing to indulge the
gender whims of children and the
children themselves have grown up in a
world where they're literally taught
there are hundreds of genders and
anybody can identify as anything they
want
but they can't
and when something like this happens
Society changes so radically and so fast
and becomes so ridiculous that it causes
complete chaos and we surely should be
questioning this it cannot simply be the
case that minority groups are right end
of question and anyone who raises
questions about it is automatically a
bigot or a transphob I'm not bigoted or
transphobic
but I do think this is insanity and the
next time a child identifies as a cat at
a school in this country they should be
told but as a mark of deep respect for
their new identity they will be taken
out of the classroom put in a cage with
other actual cats who will scratch and
bite them all day they'll be given water
whiskers tuna chunks for lunch taken the
walks on leads at break time and must
use a litter tray for a toilet one that
won't be changed for several days trust
me they'll soon be re-identifying as
humans by tea time well joining me now
is the veteran LGBT activist and Human
Rights Campaign a bit attachable
political journalist Ava Santina and by
the best-selling author conservative
commentator Douglas Murray well Douglas
York safely over there in the United
States so let me start with you before
the fun starts here
um this stuff reads like a joke but it's
really not funny when you get into the
weeds of it this is Limitless
self-identity Don bonkers
yeah it's um the very stupid results of
a very stupid idea ideology being rolled
out by very stupid people uh basically
everything has come unstuck in recent
years by the ever expanding alphabet
acronym people where the fight for gay
rights and minorities sexual rights
turned into this demand this claim that
there was no such thing as biological
sex as uh Peter tatchell and others well
no the argument for gay rights was one
by saying we just like the rest of you
it was also one by saying you know we
just want to Live and Let Live yet the
gender ideologues have done something
totally different they've said you don't
have the right to have your own say in
this we are right and you have to agree
with us they say we're here and instead
of saying we're here we're queer with
them and just get used to it it's we're
here and as a result biological reality
does doesn't exist well clearly this
very very idiotic ideology is causing
Havoc just today peers there's another a
tape from a school in Scotland where
some poor boy is having to explain to
his teacher there's only two biological
Sexes and that the gender woo-woo stuff
is nonsense and yet again it's the
student having to educate the teacher
because the teacher has been
indoctrinated into stupidity due to the
gender ideologues okay either you're
laughing why it's just quite amusing
really I mean we're talking about
children that are 12 and 13 I mean when
I was at school I had a girl who
identified as a horse but not in this
sort of like problematic way that we're
now labeling it she didn't actually
think she was a horse she was just quite
strange and walked around and you know
but nobody in the school then no
teachers would have tolerated that in
the way that this is now having to be
told no teacher would have tolerated
bullying of that child and that's what
this teacher in Sussex has done they've
said it's not acceptable for boys in
that class to take the Mickey out of
someone who's obviously clearly just a
child and they're exploring their
imagination he says they're a cat yes
yes but appears they're 12. and he's
actually interfering with the lessons by
talking in cat language including
meowing and if people don't go along
with this refusing to cooperate yeah
that is not just having a bit of fun
being a cat that is actually assuming
the identity of an animal that this
person is not yeah and then insisting
everybody else conform to it that is mad
that's not what's happening what's
happening is there's a child who's
slightly more imaginative than their
peers and they are acting out this sort
of fallacy and that's fine but to make
it about trans or to this is where it
gets dangerous okay the telegraph oh
it's very damaging to trans people I
agree right okay I agree with that
reason is most damaging the telegraph
I've been reporting this is up 400 in
the last couple of years then reporting
trans issues I don't understand why
they've got this weird obsession with
going let me explain why let me explain
why oh it's quite good let me explain
why when you have in women's sports six
foot four inch biological males
destroying biological females at Elite
Sport level in swimming pools on race
tracks in other sports that's when it
becomes a full frontal assault on
women's rights to fairness and equality
and when you include them going into
dressing rooms and so on and mixing with
biological females then there's a safety
issue when you have as we had in
Scotland a male rapist identifying at
his trial as a woman to get put into a
woman's prisons and being sent there by
the female boss of Scotland at the time
who's now obviously in her own troubles
that is why this is this is happening
kids are watching all this stuff and as
kids do they want a piece of the action
no peers don't be ridiculous there is
nothing there's no similarity between a
child wanting to be a cat when they're
12 years old and someone competing in
the Olympics oh there is there is
Peterson you and I have had a lot of
civilized conversations about all this
right and I want to continue that I
don't think that the trans Community
gets helped At All by any of this right
but I I don't think it's the media
obsessing I think what you're seeing is
as the trans Community get ever more
active and populous if you like for want
of a better phrase and their activists
get more aggressive when they go to
battle on things like women's sport
they're losing everyone and they're
piling mockery onto the trans community
if we can go back to the telegraph
article yeah it's quite mischievous out
of the I don't know million or more
pupils in our schools they come up with
five examples five examples out of a
million now that's wrong I I agree it's
wrong but as Ava says the kids are just
acting up fantasies when I was a little
kid I wanted to be Robin Hood but that's
fine that's fine but they're still the
schools should not be tolerated a
teacher should not be saying if you
don't but if you believe there are that
women have vaginas and men have penises
you have to leave the school that is
complete nonsense no right in this
particular case the telegraph site of
this handful of examples they were by
teachers individual teachers they were
not school policy and at least one case
the school disowned the teacher and the
policy and said that it wouldn't happen
but what about this case in right in Rye
College well yeah I'm sure there are
some examples of excesses but on the
basis of those exceptions you can't make
a generalized attack upon the school
system and suggests that all our kids
are being propagandized in this way
because it's simply when you hear that
teacher I think to bring uh Douglas back
in when you hear that teacher there's
clear evidence of what we've all been
fearing has been going on which is a
teacher caught on tape literally spewing
nonsensical gender ideology propaganda
but one teacher yes
one teacher caught on to take right
there'd be many other instances of this
being reported but no one's actually had
it on tape it's a bit like I would liken
it to the party gay Scandal when we
finally got a video of the people having
what was clearly a party there have been
lots of rumors about it so now we have a
teacher clearly on tape doing this but
it's not official school policy
so you're still working at that school
Douglas if I may a festival Ava rather
unfortunately misspoke earlier when she
said that the uh school girl in question
was acting out of fallacy I think you
meant a fantasy but actually she is
acting out of fallacies
do you know what's fascinating which has
been propagated a fallacy which has been
propagated by gender ideologues and is
doing profound damage to gay people
among others in our society as well as
women
explain very quickly why I can't quite
hear you but I can hear you muttering
something let me quickly explain why a
poll that just got published in the
United States showed that among the
general population support for gay
marriage has been starting to decline in
the last year why is that it's because
the arguments that actually brought
about liberal rights for all minorities
in last few decades have started to get
turned on their head and turned against
people what is the source of that it is
the gender ideology movement what is the
tripwire for the general public it is
children it is is people learning that
their children are being taught
nonsensical things it is being seen by
The Wider public most of whom are
heterosexual and don't need to identify
a CIS or anything else it is being seen
from that Vantage Point as the lgbtqia
plus movement losing control of itself
and so a backlash is starting and the
backlash is coming because people are
lying to children and are using children
for medical experiments there's nothing
funny about that there's nothing that
should cause levity in that it should be
treated by adults seriously okay so
Douglas it's really important actually
all of that point that you've just
brought up it's very on brand for you
because you know you like to stoke fear
you've actually made a career out of it
we are you know I'll take you back to
your book The Strange death of Europe
and you made a big fright you know
you've frightened the entire public
about your thoughts on Europe and we
ended up in brexit you weren't the sole
contributed to that but you were a
bigger
issue when you're talking about lgbtq
what you've just done there is basically
say that the whole of America who have
historically had a problem with gay
marriage are now turning on it because a
couple of children in a classroom in
Sussex want to be a cat if you can't see
the Ridiculousness in that argument I
can't help you no the bigger issues
there's no such thing as gender ideology
we all have gender identities you
identify as a man and I fully respect
you well no no hang on I don't identify
as a man I was born a biological hey yes
that's where this whole thing is
I'll bring you back in though as you
want to say that's where the whole
debate goes wrong you were born a
biological male you were born a
biological female Douglas biological
male this is just a fact right no once
you start saying there are hundreds of
genders and you can identify as anything
you want you're gonna up with kids at
school going I'm a horse and you've got
to treat me like all it appears you're
confusing two things sex and gender I'm
not I say I've been completed biological
sex is one thing which I totally accept
and so do 99 of the people in the LGBT
plus Community gender is something
different gender identity is how you see
yourself and do you believe this do you
believe it's Limitless no I don't
believe it's limits what's the limit
well there was basically male and female
intersex but there are people who have
different gender identity but how many
genders are there well I I there is no
fixed number so what's the limit I don't
see a particular limit there's no limit
so when you said there was no you said
there is a limit now you admit There's
No Limit sorry well there is male and
female is there a limit or not identity
no that's that's sex but on gender is
there a limit to a number of genders
well there are there are some people who
are asexual that's an identity the BBC
the BBC has put in education videos
there are a hundred plus genders well I
don't agree with that so what is the
limit what's the number well
I'm not going to specify a particular
number but it's very small where do you
drop where do you draw the line well I
draw the line based on science and
evidence and we know that there is a
thing called intersex where people are
born with a mixture of both that is
basically what it says that's what it
says that is intersex yeah people are
born with with chromosomes from both
right that is a medical condition that's
inarguable right we're talking about
gender well we're done with trans
identity is also a biological factor but
once I've rooted I'm noted in brain
structures and Pros understand it but
what's the science shows but once you
get into 100 genders people yeah we're
actually bathing 100 well actually the
BBC has taught kids as it's back to
Douglas's point about you know affecting
the brains of impressionable young kids
I don't agree with that I don't agree
with the BBC plus genders okay Douglas
uh very quickly I I don't know Ava
anything about your career
um I don't know if you have one but you
did try to imply that you knew something
about mine and you just showed you know
nothing about it because actually my
2017 bestseller the strange death of
Europe was not about about the EU so you
should learn at some point to read more
than the title it was about your
commenting
but let me let me very quickly
how rude quickly very quickly career out
of fearing
ideas
you've both got wonderful careers or you
wouldn't be on Piers Morgan and
sentencing uh Before I Let You Go Peter
though I want a quick reaction Elton
John today reacted to the Phillip
Schofield Scandal and said that he
believed uh it was totally homophobic
that if it had been a man having a
relationship at work with a 20 year old
woman there would be no Scandal what's
your response to that I think there's a
whiff of homophobia I wouldn't say total
homophobia there's a whiff because we
know that when big celebrities like
Leonardo DiCaprio
um uh Peter Stringfellow uh Elvis
Presley and so on when they had
relationships with young women much much
younger there was tutting but there
wasn't the kind of witch hunting
atmosphere that Philip Schofield has
experienced now saying that as someone
who says that you know his own private
life should be his own private life
unless he's harmed someone else or
committed a criminal offense otherwise
it's for him you know 40 of uh all
marriages used to begin at the workplace
and historically with a a man and a
higher position at work that's how
people used to meet and fall in love it
would be the boss the second Trends on
that's not going to happen anymore is it
I mean with the Scofield template now is
you cannot actually really have any
relationships at work and my only
response to that would be okay how are
people going to meet their partners for
life actually it's an interesting
question socially if 40 of marriages
began at work and work relationships
become taboo
the only thing we should be concerned
about what was a crime committed was
anyone harmed we don't have any evidence
of either in the case of no we don't at
the moment unless unless the the other
man concerned comes out and contradicts
Phillips story there is no crime until
then the man is innocent yeah until
proven guilt I don't disagree Peter we
reach a point of agreement always a good
place to end Ava congratulations on your
stunning career which has brought you to
the desk of beers Morgan and said
Douglas always a joy over there in New
York great to see you
as a cat Fleet uncensored next rescue
teams are in a deadly Race Against Time
after a tourist sub carrying five very
rich people but missing on a dive to the
wreck of the Titanic
could they possibly survive this is
there any hope we'll have the latest
next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
before we came on air the U.S Coast
Guard updated the world on their search
and rescue mission to find a missing
Titanic submersible it wasn't good news
so far their efforts have not yielded
any results five people are on board the
tiny vesselton British billionaire
Explorer Hamish Harding they're said to
have fewer than 40 hours of oxygen
remaining
so could this be a rescue mission
impossible well the remains of a Titanic
where some are speculated in the sub
could be stuck rests 12 and a half
thousand feet beneath the surface of the
Atlantic at that depth no light from the
Sun reaches the ocean floor it's pitch
black temperatures are near freezing
around 0 to 3 degrees Celsius water
pressure is 380 times greater than our
land that's the equivalent of being
trapped under a hundred Story Tower made
of lead and to illustrate just how deep
it is twelve and a half thousand feet is
about nine Empire State Building stacked
on top of each other well joining me now
are exploring friend of British
businessman Hamish Harding uh Yannick
Mickelson retired U.S Navy submarine
Captain David Markey and Dr Michael yeen
who's a journalist who became the first
TV correspondent in history to report
from the wreck of the Titanic well
welcome to all of you
um Jenny let me let me start with you
Yannick if I may obviously a
devastatingly difficult time for you and
everybody who knows any of the he's five
people on board how are you feeling
about this because obviously Hamish
great Explorer done many very risky
things in his time but this as time goes
on does look to be potentially like a
real tragedy unfairly
it's looking Bleak I'm terrified for the
worst news now it's
um I have a little bit of Hope but they
have all the odds against them at this
point and it will be a miracle if they
can recover the summary they're
submersible with a crew that's alive
what kind of man is Hamish for those who
don't know him
Hamish is larger than life uh he loves
exploration he's been to space he's been
to the deepest point of the planet he's
been to the South Pole and he's also
mentored me a lot in my career as a
Explorer and this is why I'm living
close to the North Pole to train to be a
polar Explorer and survive in a Polar
climate
there are videos of I think Hamish and
others talking about this this vessel
the submersible the thing that struck me
was that for people who were so wealthy
it doesn't seem a particularly
sophisticated piece of Machinery that
the risks are pretty high actually
something was to go wrong would that be
a fair assessment
I myself haven't seen this submersible
but with any Expedition there's a large
amount of risk involved if you want to
be the first person to do something
today on planet Earth or in space you
have to accept risk because if it was
easy it wouldn't have been done
um David you've been a retired United
States Navy submarine Captain so an
expert in this field I want to play a
little bit of what I'm just talking
about a little clip of some of the
people who are on board talking before
about it including Hamish
an experimental submersible vessel that
has not been approved or certified by
any regulatory body and could result in
physical injury disability emotional
trauma or death
where do I sign I couldn't help noticing
how many pieces of this sub seemed
improvised we can use these
off-the-shelf components I got these
from uh Camper World We Run the whole
thing with this game controller
[Music]
so do
they've sort of been quite jokey about
it obviously this is now a very serious
situation
um did they underestimate perhaps the
dangers or is that just always part of
the risk you think of this kind of
expedition
no I think you could do a better job
mitigating the risk we know from a long
history of operating submarines in the
Royal Navy the American Navy I've been
underwater for 87 continuous days what
it takes to keep a sudden rating
operating safely underwater we have
first of all starts with the design and
the building of the submarine we track a
bolt from when it was manufactured let's
say it's chromium magnesium alloy two
when it's installed on the submarine
every step of the way because we want to
make sure that the exact right bolt with
the right material is installed in a
right bolt hole this all costs money and
then when we operate the submarine if we
were in Port for a while we don't just
go out and submerge in deep water and
see how it goes we we test everything at
the pier then we go deliberately 100
feet 200 feet 300 feet walk around with
flashlights checking things it is
daunting and this is why these
submarines cost so much money so I
admire people pushing the boundaries and
throughout the human race these people
have contributed a lot
and some risk is unavoidable but I think
you should try and do everything you can
to minimize avoidable risk what David
what do you think is the most likely
scenario that's happened here
well uh for the families and friends
prepare yourself for bad news
the communications abruptly ended
and the submarine has not shown up on
the surface so to me that signifies the
likely that the crew has been
incapacitated it could be simply that
the batteries die but in this case I
would expect to hear someone banging a
wrench for example against the titanium
and bells of the submarine but we're not
hearing anything so I worry that there's
something there could have been a
firearm board they could have somehow
depleted their oxygen way early and not
realize that they could have flooded
somehow A fitting corroded and ruptured
and water came in and when you're that
deep you said 380 times the pressure at
air that's just the number it's hard to
conceive how that happens like this the
water would come in so fast they
wouldn't experience anything they would
be crushed they would be drowned they'd
be asphyxiated and they would feel no
pain what is the difference between a
submarine and a submersible
a submarine has a big motor a big engine
and a propeller that drives it out of
port so it's on its own leaves Port uh
leaves Norfolk goes out to sea drives a
Thousand Mile submerges and and operates
a submersible has small maneuvering
propellers so it's towed out to the side
of the Titanic it's released by the
mother ship it can drive down hover
around the wreck uses those propellers
because there's currents down there so
it uses those propellers to make sure it
doesn't get swept into the Rack or
entangled in the rack and then when when
they're done sightseeing and the time's
up then they come back up to the surface
well thank you for the expert uh
guidance too because I think a lot of
people are a little bit confused Dr
Michael you know better than most the
difference you've been honest
submersible in 2000 you went down there
for ABC News you were the first TV
correspondent in history to report from
the wreck of the Titanic at the bottom
of the ocean we've got a little clip of
this I think
approach the stern
current that pushes us towards one of
the gigantic 21 ton propellers look at
the size of these things oh my gosh so
are we stuck or what
as this graphic shows we appear to be
somehow wedged beneath the wreck of the
stern
a scary moment for you uh does this
bring back pretty awful memories of what
happened to you and what could have
happened
yeah
I'm feeling pretty sick right now
and uh
agree with that Lieutenant uh the two
things that um
come out at me right now is the loss of
communications because even when we were
stuck down there our pilot chose a
former Russian Nick pilot who's piloting
our three-man sub much smaller than the
one that's currently in its situation
and uh he was able to communicate with
the surface ship the research vessel the
academic kelvish on the surface I
couldn't understand what they were
saying it was all in Russian but
nevertheless and then the second thing
that stands out uh to me Pierce is
um as a lieutenant pointed out if it had
just been a failure of communications
then that pilot would have brought that
thing up to the surface immediately so I
mean uh we can speculate endlessly I
hate doing it because lives are at stake
utterly hopeless it's not easy to get
out of there I can see the emotion there
in you that this is obviously and and
indeed also for you uh Yani um because
Dr Michael I guess
you must have had a moment when you were
in a similar situation where you thought
you may not get out of it right
yeah more than a moment uh the better
part of an hour and uh being a scientist
of course I'm a professional Problem
Solver so my first instinct was number
one to hope nobody in the cabin would
panic because we had been told uh by the
captain of our ship before we went down
that he told us a story a true story of
a gentleman who has found himself in
that situation and in his Panic went for
the escape hatch to open it up it's
right above your head and of course that
was the end of it because it's the cap
as the lieutenant said the precious down
there enormous
um I filed a story for 2020 and then
Good Morning America and just to
illustrate how how powerful the pressure
is down there we took uh some styrofoam
cups and the cup came back about that
small when all the air had been squeezed
out of it from the pressure down there
that brings it home it's a very hostile
environment very cold very high pressure
um so
uh yes for the better part of an hour I
kept thinking well how can we get out of
this there was another Russian sub in
the vicinity and I thought perhaps it
could tell us out but of course it's not
feasible it's not AAA it comes to you
out of the month
um and I just ran through the checklist
of things in my mind and I finally came
to that moment that brick wall that
utter sense of uh hopelessness and the
words that came into my mind were this
is how it's going to end for you and you
have to understand I've been to the
North Pole the South Pole I've covered
the Persian Gulf War for 14 years ABC
news I've been all over the world I've
Been In Harm's Way everywhere but those
words came into my mind and I'll never
forget it this is how it's going to end
for you and I thought of my wife Laura
thought I'd never see her again just by
the grace of God Victor and his skill
managed to weasel her way out of that
big propeller it's a big propeller our
ship was very small you have to
understand it's a huge propeller our
ship is small in comparison we just got
trapped in the blades but if it weren't
for Victor's hero efforts of I wouldn't
be here today to tell you about this but
it's just terrible it makes me sick well
incredibly emotive uh description there
from someone who really does know what
they may I mean look you had a miracle
Escape we can only hope and pray that
something may turn up here we don't know
obviously what's happened until we know
for sure there's hope and they they
would still have enough oxygen left if
indeed they're still alive and we can
only hope and pray that does happen and
Yannick for you and for everyone who's a
friend a family member our hearts go out
to all of you and we just hope and pray
that there is a miraculous ending to
this but thank you all very much indeed
for joining me I appreciate it
thank you peers
well since the next you probably need
some light relief after that what an
emotional description there of what may
be down there by the Titanic what that
experience must be like when you fear
the worst
um really very moving
after the break we're gonna I like the
load we're gonna talk about Cricket uh
just in the most remarkable end to a
game between England and Australia in
the uh ashes series just started here in
England prompting my belief that Cricket
is the greatest sport in the world but
Americans a lot of Americans think it's
the most boring and stupidest sport in
the world the debate this after the
break the qriket legend David Lloyd and
U.S commentated Dave portney who hasn't
got a clear clue what I've just been
talking about
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
please
welcome back to peers organization
England tonight lost a thrilling first
ashes test match to Australia I'm
actually gutted about it but despite
that I remain adamant the cricket is
indisputedly the greatest sport of them
all many Australians will agree
especially tonight but many of our
viewers in the United States well they
wouldn't agree in fact they think
Cricket is one of the most boring
confusing and pointlessports ever
invented here are some of our American
friends watching Cricket for the very
first time
so the pitcher is trying to hit these
sticks maybe y'all Dead catching the
ball with their hands is the balls off
what just happened
what just happened off his leg up in the
air he knows it's coming at him I think
in the back big yeah
this is the most complicated sport I
ever seen bro
that's the key we made it deliberately
complicated so Americans wouldn't want
to play it think about that I'm not
stupid over here so is Cricket the
greatest sport in the world as I believe
or are we Brits and Aussies and a few
other countries just completely Bonkers
to debate this I'm joined by the bar
stool Sports founder Dave Portnoy in the
United States and from Yorkshire former
England cricket player umpire coach and
living legend David fumble Lloyd all
right Dave Poley uh you obviously don't
don't get Cricket that might be your
problem not ours because Cricket is the
greatest sport ever invented
listen uh Pierce I thought there's a
misprint on the sheet when they said
what you were asking me to talk about I
Cricket I mean I've seen five seconds of
cricket my whole life I'm not against
Cricket I just don't care about Cricket
uh I just heard the introduction you
gave to the the guy in the panel I mean
if he was walking down the street and
slapped me in the face I'd have no idea
who he was I just don't know anything
about Cricket I've seen the highlights I
know that you can play for like 3 000
hours straight it seems interesting if
you know what's going on but it's not an
American sport it's our version of
baseball but yeah I don't care about
Cricket at all oh you're not gonna get
me to trash Cricket but I don't know
anything about it all right David Lloyd
enthused the gentleman explain why he's
so wrong to be so disinterested
because I'm not surprised that they
don't get it in America I really don't
and baseball's been mentioned and that
goes right above me America what is it
football they play when they're all you
can't tell anybody they've all got hats
on they've all got shoulders on and they
throw it around in fact they bring the
crowd in they can have a go as well so
don't talk about crickets the greatest
sport has ever been I'm not surprised in
the slightest look who's running the
country
well Davey's got a point I mean you've
got a you've got a present at the moment
who's I don't know what that point is I
well I'll tell you what the point is the
point is you argue I don't I don't care
about Cricket no I if crickets here and
there nowhere again I thought it was
amazing all right let me try and be
trying to explain to you let me try to
explain to you why you should you guys
are the ones who need the respect for
cricket cricket who cares about Cricket
here we're explaining you why you're
wrong it's not about the point of this
segment well I'm telling you the point
of the segment so get this little fact
about cricket cricket matches were
played by soldiers during the American
Revolutionary War with many games being
played at the Valley Forge encampment
George Washington I'm sure you've heard
of him also played at least one game
there with the sport referred to as
Wicket by Americans at the time not the
first time you've taken our language and
mangled it
um so cricket was very much there at the
start what happened why did you move to
baseball which is so clearly that speaks
volumes about
that speaks volumes about cricket being
boring if you're saying we had it all
these years we developed better Sports
more I mean people people play the cross
way back in the day and it didn't grow I
don't know I didn't know this turned
into we got the Fourth of July around
the corner and you got me coming at
Cricket for I'll tell you I'll tell you
one thing that is dumb can't the same
guy pitch every time
no that's the whole point that's why our
formula you can't go on your hand can't
the same picture
no we don't play underhand anything all
throw it we don't do that we bowl and we
have great fielding positions like
sitting together
right no we we all together all right
you want me to say crickets great
Cricket's great I don't care Cricket's
great great go Cricket I don't all right
they go to any sport they've got a few
golfers are they any good at snooker or
darts what they got
[Laughter]
is
being telecast is this is this show only
in Sydney Australia or something I don't
even know what we're talking about it
does air in Sydney but snooker rather
like Cricket is to baseball is a
sophisticated version of pool we
basically have more Superior
sophisticated intelligent sport here
probably why you don't like them though
cool
we're talking about pool valve yes
all right I mean I don't know that you
got world-class athletes playing pool
but
well Dave Dave for those who don't
understand Cricket in America and care
even less and just think it's a waste of
time I always explain how could you not
enjoy yourself
it's just not an American story I'm
actually talking to the other David here
hang on David Lloyd the legend Bumble
we'll call you
um I always explained to Americans that
take the ashes it's five matches
spreader each one over five days each
day can be seven to eight hours you can
get 200 hours of cricket and at the end
the score might be zero zero and that's
why we devised it like that so Americans
would never want to play it
well it's coming to America if you
listen to everybody about T20 which is
the dumbest form of the game T20 he's
quick he's fast he's lightning and it's
coming to America whether they like it
or not it's on its way yeah it is and
Dave portney I'm afraid you are going to
grow to love Cricket you're going to
want to come on here every week and do
Cricket segments
I don't know what he just said Cricket's
Coming to America where at the local
YMCA is coming to cities All Over
America the three-hour version we could
introduce you to football and rugby as
well you you're no good at that
rugby I've seen rugby
you don't look to me I just you guys are
trying to make me like a cricket hater I
just don't know much about it the way
you should describe it you said it goes
on for seven days straight with no
points and no goals that sounds like a
torture captain
uh look two days with very different
opinions about Cricket I have to say
David Lloyd for me Cricket has brought
me more joy as I know it has for you
than anything else probably in my entire
life with a possible exception of hand
because you're an Arsenal fan Bob
certainly more joy sustain Joy than
Arsenal and probably as much joy as a
hand-pumped part of Harvey's bitter
which I know uh David Lloyd you you love
a bit of bitter as well don't you I do
indeed and and we're gonna have to get
older Dave and take him to him
he'll have to come kick in and screaming
for seven days we'll play it for seven
days
we have a day David Portnoy we're going
to take you to a qriket match and we're
gonna bore you into submission to
Superior form of baseball uh to date two
Davis thank you both very much indeed
for an enlightening debate we've got
absolutely nowhere but it was very funny
thank you both very much uh uncensored
next the British water company announces
a review of its maintenance signs after
claims the phrase Men at Work is sexist
of course it is only a matter of time
before they came for the Workman uh
we'll debate that next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk a missing
submarine with five on board only has 40
hours of oxygen left as the rescue
mission is in a Race Against Time Meghan
Markle is accused of Faking interviews
in her podcast and the Miss England
beauty pageant looks to bring back the
bikini round that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to uh Facebook tonight's
pack let's talk to these from Lauren
Adrian and Richard Tice great to see
women getting their kid off again in
beauty contest isn't it
hey
over to you Paula well that that depends
peers is that what you're into watching
women getting there I like seeing
beautiful women uh in bikinis you like
judging them yeah but you rate a woman
no problem at all and Men okay so I'm
I'm happy to judge you both really rate
you both would you like well I wouldn't
want to be a joke I wouldn't want to be
objectified I'm sure Richard
constantly no composition between them I
don't know let's do it let's see yeah
but what is it what's the big deal about
those kind of competitions with women
who just want to be beautiful models
it's not 1970 anymore
and to
and just about the bikini especially
well it was well nobody cared about what
they said for you maybe cared about the
interviews yeah I I think that's quite
disappointing and says a lot really
about you not more so than it says about
the world I think we should be able to
rather like a fine piece of art we
should be able to appreciate beauty
without being judged censoriously for
appreciating that's exactly what you're
doing you're judging them that's what
you've just told me literally women walk
down the street now in bikinis without
any problem what's the big deal and so
what is the problem with that well
they're not being judged and they're not
being objectified want to be judged just
the whole point of entry in competition
not just about the bikini they want to
be judged and that's why they took it
they literally enter a competition to be
judged it's about convention it's about
being the best by the way there's a clue
in the title beauty pageant they want to
be Miss America or Miss Universe they
want to be Miss UK they want to be
judged so now they look ah so when you
say Miss UK what they're not saying is I
want to be miss beautiful UK that's
again that's
ugly UK then I watch it I'd watch this
ugly UK
um look here's some pictures of a former
beauty pageant contestants right all
very happy to be in it all very happy to
be judged I was very happy looking at
those shows over the years what's the
problem what's the problem I don't mind
if it's men if you women want to look at
men you Ogle people like the pole dark
guy all the time what's the difference
Aiden what's his name from poldark Front
Page every paper with his top off every
year women all go crazy what's the
difference there isn't any well we know
what the difference is it's just you're
choosing not to accept it let's talk
about Men at Work science okay something
that's contentious so apparently a water
company been blasted by uh worrying
about causing a fence for having Men at
Work signs put up an excellent Endeavor
they've ordered a review following a
complaint that it deems women's
contributions unimportant Richard tires
have you ever seen a woman on one of
these water construction sites working
never writing about so it's not about
50s it is incredibly Men at Work it's a
fact they're just describing a fact
which men are at work yeah I mean it's
not rocket science it's not very
difficult it's not offensive maybe it
was women at work I'd say make the same
women at work in a Maternity Ward no
maybe there should be a sign saying
women Bishop pushing hard I don't know
oh do you know what I I don't know
whether to be scared or worried because
this is quite unbelievable why do we
need a sign to say Men at Work why do
you need that sign because you've
literally so most constructive sites are
very low that you need a size
it's not about what mostly happens oh
what about generalizing this is about
even if there aren't any women it should
say men at work it's about health and
safety it's about working it's about
working
so unfortunately our work has come to a
tragic end
just change the sign back to what it was
that's it for me Keep It Uncensored Men
at Work if they're men what's the
problem
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign